said you know what send us the third
funniest guy
wait he's unavailable send a shack let
us get shaq then
uh i'm loving the uh the weight
adjustment that you guys had to make
with that table because of check
shack and chuck that's a that's a pretty
fat ass
check and chuck that's what that is
right well uh
kevin i can see that uh you know jumanji
must ain't do that well you got the
little ass diamonds on you couldn't come
out of this pandemic with a better suit
option
i'm so sick of you and chucking these
awful suits y'all be wearing looking
like two beacons has anybody ever seen a
shack fall
i see this this is [ __ ] he goes for a
rebound he doesn't get his
oh no oh oh god no
he's just down there
check will go to the line
blaze is stuck in the air it's the worst
thing ever nobody can help him up
because he's too big so you just gotta
wait
you gotta wait he's just there for a
while it's like a turtle
like a really fat baby look at shaq shaq
shaq hasn't taken this shirt off since
high school okay that's a true story
that's a true stupid right there
babe shaq don't have no lips it's just
gums attached to his beard
[Laughter]
shaq got gums
it's just all gums hey why is your wife
beater connected to your beard you got a
little too much black
i don't know his clothes
tell your wife tell your wife if i got
to
tell you what i got some new baby uh car
baby seats
for when she want to kiss your little
ass
why do you feel like you have to attack
my height shaq you do know that you are
you're little cause you're a little man
nobody's your size
nobody else is your size ain't nobody is
your size
it's you and yao
big dumb giants just two [ __ ]
that they can never get the size shoot
for come on man
i can't get shack in there hold on hold
on
[Laughter]
real quick though just saying that in a
flip joint man how you felt about the
show
what you thought god bless and good
night what is that
saying how you felt you said god bless
and good night
did you have a good time jesus
happy holidays merry christmas very
merry
if you're jewish happy harmonica
okay okay that's it it's go time let's
go chuck throw me the ball
all right yeah me and you charles let's
go
come on oh jesus christ [ __ ] babe look
at this man feet
shut got it look at shaq's foot
[Music]
your foot look like a deer hook what the
[ __ ] is happening man
jesus christ
your foot's got it that's 28 000 points
four rings
what is shaq doing since his retirement
he has nothing to do he's in the most
random places
well thank you
[Laughter]
thank you very much yeah yeah i'm
serious i saw him like home depot two
weeks ago just but
yeah he was helping people like he
wasn't even shopping he was just helping
people
put stuff in the car i'm shocked i don't
have nothing to do you want me to grab
it i'll help you
he has nothing to do with his time right
[Applause]
now
[Applause]
running around i don't need to tell my
babies that you say hi
you're a giant they hear you your voice
knows that's going through it
but i want them to see my face so they
can say hi that's awesome
that'll scare him no it will not scare
him
i bet
if my son cry if my son cried i want the
money we end up paying them it
i need you too
so say hi hi
hi hi my name is uncle jack
say hi oh you're so smart
[Music]
he's scary
[Music]
yeah scared you a little bit i love you
it's okay son i know i got it yeah say
bye bye
say bye oh
[Music]
you